on
c'est aujourd'hui
puisque je vous en mets c'est un luxueux
complexe dans les résidents tous atteint
l'âge de la maturité dans le genre que
steve brava oui et avec plus d'éléphants
c'est votre première visite en inde je
trouve que ce pays est le plus civilisé
ton mardi du magic
je vous souhaite la bienvenue au palais
exotiques du marais gold hôtels
canadiens dans la pièce ce palais
trônera encore pour des millénaires je
me suis dit que j'avais le réparer moi
même si vous commencez vous serez à 100%
vous feriez ça sans la moindre
hésitation tout de suite dans trois mois
que vous sentez bien j'aurai bien verre
d'eau sur ses terres et gin tonic des
faits confirment qu un rêve d'un petit
jeu le créer un refuge pour les anciens
où ils se sentiront si bien qu'ils ont
tout simplement refusé de mourir cet
homme est décédé suis en enfer
comment supportez-vous cet endroit
qu'est ce que vous voyez dans ce pays
que je n'aime pas la lumière les
couleurs les visages sourire et la
manière qu'ont les gens de voir la vie
va bien se passer d'entrée de jeu sera
une expérience une prégnance
l'histoire tout finit par s'arranger
donc c'est pas arranger ça doit pas être
la fin histoire
c'est vrai que ça peut être dangereux
quand l'amour à votre âge doit il rester
à l'histoire